[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date lundi
d'interdire vendredi le président de la
république emmanuel macron annoncé son
projet de loi contre le séparatisme
ce matin le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin a déclaré qu'en fait le
beau séparatisme dont le président nous
avait pourtant justifié l'emploi pendant
une heure ne figurerait pas dans
l'intitulé du projet de loi qui devrait
s'appeler à la place projet de loi
renforçant la laïcité et les principes
républicains la laïcité donc dont le
président nous avait pourtant dit
vendredi qu'elle n'était pas le problème
le problème pour lui c'était le
séparatisme islamistes
alors pourquoi changement qu'est ce
qu'ils signifient pour en débattre nous
avons invité bernard godard vous avez
été officier de police aux
renseignements généraux puis chargé de
mission au bureau central des cultes du
ministère de l'intérieur en charge des
relations avec le culte musulman vous
est d'ailleurs l'auteur de la question
musulmane en france un état des lieux
sans concession paru chez fayard en 2015
il ya déjà beaucoup de lois
à la fois contre le fanatisme religieux
contre contre les dérives sectaires
est-ce qu'il faut il fallait une loi de
plus à votre avis pas du tout pas du
tout avoir
si on parle de séparatisme et j'ai bien
compris qu'on parle plutôt de terrorisme
d'une part et de communautarisme des
genres mélange les deux et donc du coup
c'est pas très clair mais deux
dispositifs en matière d'antiterrorisme
il existe il ya eu des lois à la suite
des attentats 2015 ça c'est une chose et
ensuite concernant la laïcité il ya la
loi dino des rapports avec les cultes il
ya la loi de 1905
il ya peut-être des aménagements oui
pourquoi pas c'est une bonne idée mais
si vous voulez le socle est là et il n'y
a pas de raison de faire une nouvelle
loi
omar slaouti vous êtes enseignant dans
un lycée de la grande banlieue vous êtes
membre du collectif vérité et justice
pour ali ziri vous avez été l'un des
porte parole de la marche pour la
justice et la dignité contre les
violences policières en 2017 et l'un des
initiateurs de la marche contre
l'islamophobie qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre l'année dernière c'est
vous sous votre direction et celle
d'olivier le le cour grandmaison qui est
publié à la découverte un gros livre
collectif intitulé racisme de france
avec plus de plus de 20 que contributeur
si je me souviens bien
est-ce qu'il fallait une louve nouvelle
loi on a déjà des lois contre les
dérives sectaires contre le fanatisme
religieux contre le terrorisme est ce
qu'on a besoin d'une nouvelle loi
non évidemment nous on se la couronne à
faire ici c'est véritablement une loi de
diversion y reviendra sur le fond on a
l'état d'urgence qui est rentré dans la
loi depuis 2015 et en plus de ça il ya
eu la loi site depuis en 2017
la loi gatel il ya des cellules
départementales de lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
les préfets font à peu près tout ce
qu'ils veulent donc globalement on a
évidemment pas de l'oie et c'est pour ça
que cette loi qui arrivait à ce
moment-là il dit beaucoup de choses sauf
ce que monsieur macron veut nous faire
croire à la au quilit vous vous êtes 10
présidente de nous sommes leur voie une
association de défense des femmes
quand vous présente dans les émissions
de télévision auquel vous participez on
ajoute que vous êtes contributrice au
magazine causeur alors va pour causeur
pour vous on a besoin d'une nouvelle loi
ou pas bonsoir oui je pense
effectivement qu'on a aujourd'hui besoin
d'une nouvelle loi
comme mon prédécesseur viens de le dire
il y en a eu énormément
visiblement elles n'ont pas eu d'effet
parce que contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur godard le terrorisme oui il y a
des lois contre mais le terrorisme n'est
qu'un moyen qui est en fait le bras armé
d'une action politique
l'action politique dont il est question
mène son combat par en ouvrant plusieurs
fronts à l'école dans l'associatif et
cetera je pense que effectivement il ya
besoin d'harmoniser la politique qui
vise à lutter contre tous là pour
qu'enfin nous puissions retrouver un
semblant de paix
olivier le cour grandmaison vous
enseigner les sciences politiques et la
philosophie politique à l'université
paris saclay evry val d'essonne vous
êtes l'auteur de nombreux livres dont la
république impériale politique et
racisme d'état
c'était sous la france coloniale et ses
sous votre direction et celle d'omar
slaouti qu'est publié elle est
découverte racisme de france qui compte
23 contributeurs universitaires
journalistes militants pour vous on a
besoin d'une nouvelle loi ou pas je
parte à ce qui a été dit par omar
slaouti l'intervenant précédent et je
crois en plus de cela que le discours d'
emmanuel macron et la précision apportée
par gérald darmanin la miss l'intérieur
témoigne d'une tout à fait singulière un
préparation de ce discours
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un fond un
cafouillage politique au plus haut
niveau de l'état on nous annonçait
depuis très longtemps un grand discours
prétendument fondateur est supposé
marqué la seconde partie du quinquennat
des quinquennats d' emmanuel macron sur
la question du séparatisme
il prononce ce discours et 24 heures
plus tard aux 48 heures plus tard
le terme supposé être au coeur de ce
dispositif politico juridique est enlevé
et donc je considère que
il s'agit effectivement me semble-t-il
d'une part d'une opération de diversion
politique assurément mais en plus de
cela d'une sorte de bricolage politico
idéologique qui au fond va accoucher
d'une souris sans doute législatives
absolument inutile au regard
effectivement de l'ensemble des
dispositions déjà adopté antérieurement
alors les faits il n'est plus question
de séparatisme doublé d'un projet de loi
pour renforcer la laïcité et les
principes républicains je vous propose
de retrouver emmanuel macron vendredi au
moment même où il nous expliquait que ça
n'était pas un problème de laïcité
le problème ce n'est pas la laïcité gelé
plusieurs fois rappelé la laïcité en
république française c'est la liberté de
croire ou de ne pas croire la
possibilité d'exercer son culte
à partir du moment où l'ordre public et
assurer la laïcité c'est la neutralité
de l'état et en aucun cas l'effacement
des religions dans la société dans
l'espace public
la laïcité c'est le ciment de la france
unie si la spiritualité relève du
domaine de chacun la laïcité est notre
affaire à tous et donc les républicains
sincères ne doivent jamais céder à ceux
qui au nom du principe de laïcité tente
de susciter des divisions des
confrontations à partir de multiples
sujets qui bien souvent sont l'essentiel
de nos discussions mais pas l'essentiel
du problème
en la matière nous avons des règles il
nous faut les faire respecter fermement
et justement partout sans concession
de la même manière ne nous laissons pas
entraîner dans le piège de la malle
gamme tendu par les polémistes et par
les extrême qui consisterait à
stigmatiser tous les musulmans
ce piège c'est d'ailleurs celui que nous
tendent les ennemis la république qui
consisterait à faire de chaque citoyen
de confession musulmane un allié
objectif parce qu'il serait la victime
d'un système bien organisé
trop facile ce à quoi nous devons nous
attaquer c'est le séparatisme islamistes
c'est un projet conscient théorisé
politico religieux qui se concrétise par
des écarts répétés avec les valeurs de
la république qui se traduit souvent par
la constitution d'une contre société et
dont les manifestations sont la
déscolarisation des enfants le
développement de pratiques sportifs
culturels communautariser qui sont le
prétexte pour l'enseignement de principe
qui ne sont pas conformes aux lois de la
république
c'est l'endoctrinement et par celui ci
la négation de nos principes l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
dignité humaine alors est ce que c'est
un problème de laïcité ou est-ce que ça
n'est pas un problème de laïcité à la
oukili pour vous alors je pense que ce
que le président voulait dire par là
c'était bien sur la laïcité c'est à dire
l'esprit même de la sécularisation ce
n'est pas le problème
le problème c'est qui c'est ce qui tend
à l'attaqué effectivement donc en cela
moi je ne pense pas qu'ils dérogent en
fait finalement elles sont est ce qu'il
a dit au début en dénonçant le
séparatisme islamistes et en voulant
renforcer la laïcité c'est pas la loi de
1905 dont il parle c'est l'esprit même
de la laïcité qui est rappelons le la
victoire des non croyants sur les
croyants et c'est ce que je reproche
d'ailleurs au président de la république
quand il dit à un moment ce n'est pas la
négation des religions c'est leur libre
expression dans l'espace public
bien entendu
mais c'est aussi l'expression libre de
l'athéisme dans l'espace public et c'est
bien aujourd'hui ça le plus grand signal
auxquels il faut prêter attention quand
on voit que des personnes qui
revendiquent leur athéisme et leur
liberté de critiquer les religions se
retrouve sous protection policière
menacé de mort qui le paient au prix du
sang comme les journalistes de charlie
hebdo
donc voilà il faut peut-être qu'on
insiste sur cela pour comprendre de quoi
il s'agit
rappelons que la laïcité c'est un point
d'équilibré beaucoup de nos opposants
veille toujours à l'exprimer des a donné
l'impression que la laïcité en fait
c'est la position la plus radicale
visiblement même un nouveau culte qui
s'est créée contre les musulmans
absolument pas il ne faut pas oublier
qu'il ya des personnes agnostiques
athées qui représente bien plus que les
croyants en france et qu'elles ont elles
aussi le droit de s'exprimer selon leurs
convictions ou absence de conviction est
que aujourd'hui il y à une idéologie qui
les menace et qu'il faut effectivement
la faire reculer pour que tout le monde
ait le droit à la même égalité dans ce
pays olivier le cour grandmaison d'un
problème de laïcité ou pas non je
constate avec que l'extrait que vous
avez judicieusement passer effectivement
cette espèce de pas de deux on lui dit
que c'est pas la laïcité et ensuite on
nous dit que la question fondamentale
c'est celle du séparatisme pour arriver
troisième temps un retour à la case
départ
sur le fond au fond cidre et ce n'est
pas à véritablement mon problème je
pense que cette affaire est une
gigantesque affaire de diversion
politico médiatique
je suis surpris et je pense que les
historiens à l'avenir seront surpris de
constater que alors que nous sommes
confrontés à la crise sanitaire qui est
sans doute la plus grave depuis la
grippe espagnole au sortir de la
première guerre mondiale aux effets à la
fois économiques financiers et sociaux
de cette crise je rappelle que un
certain nombre d'éléments et de la
statistique ont été fournis plus d'un
million de personnes basculent dans la
pauvreté
le secours populaire français constatent
que des centaines de milliers ou des
dizaines de milliers de français
s'adresse de nouveau à eux et on vient
nous dire que le combat essentiel qui
doit être aujourd'hui menée et placer au
plus haut de l'agenda politique
institutionnel et législatif c'est la
lutte contre le séparatisme
je crois qu'il ya là un tour de
passe-passe politique et médiatique
auquel il ne faut pas avait cédé et qui
doit être effectivement dénoncé dans la
mesure où il me semble que les problèmes
de l'heure les problèmes les plus
urgents ne sont absolument pas cela dans
la coda he les vrais problèmes au départ
sur l'emploi de ce mot séparatisme que
je récuse absolument et que finalement
ne vais pas dire grand chose sinon qu'on
sait très bien que c'est racisme je peux
le comprendre pour les catalans ou pour
les corses mais je ne comprends pas du
tout ce que ça veut dire par rapport aux
musulmans et à l'islam en particulier
mais ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien
retenir c'est que tout ça c'est ça ne
vient pas de nulle part et surtout lia
koeman déjà depuis une vingtaine
d'années un courant qui effectivement
parle d'un envahissement dit cela mais
c'est d'abord pas revenir là-dessus mais
que les attentats ont changé le logiciel
d ont changé le jeu ciel parce que
l'effet de ciment on a accrédité l'idée
que effectivement ces attentats de 2015
c'était une amende de la radicalisation
mais que c'était une islamisation de la
radicalisation de l'islam en général
dans le monde et je pense que le
président de la république est très
influencé par ce point de vue disons le
quai du point de vue de dieu ne le
universitaire gilles kepel et de talent
de ces deux de ses protégés bernard
augier qui effectivement pour lesquels
il faut démontrer que s'il voulait c'est
l'islam qui pose problème à l'avenir
alors bien sûr c'est ces universitaires
dans leur ouvrage ne dise pas que les
musulmans seront à reprocher on peut
leur reprocher des choses mais on a
changé quand même le point de vue parce
que le point de vue jusqu'à 2015
c'était calais les bons musulmans à
l'école cela il faut les protéger
et puis avec les terroristes et les
mauvais musulmans et il y avait deux
poids deux mesures chaque fois qu'un
pouvoir politique prenne une décision
par rapport à cette situation
il y avait toujours jusque usa le
hermes la carotte et le bâton c'est à
dire que l'on disait d'un côté on va
faire la loi sur le niqab et d'un autre
on va instituer la recension des actes
anti-musulmans là bon déjà ça avait
commencé avec manuel valls en 2012
mais là vraiment on est on n'a plus du
tout de cadeaux à faire voilà les
musulmans voilà vous êtes là vous êtes
confrontés à une radicale autres
religions maintenant prouvez nous que
vous n'êtes pas radicaliser que
effectivement vous faites le nécessaire
pour éviter cette vague
voilà omar slaouti ouais je crois que
avec le discours de maquereaux on a eu
une véritable démonstration du racisme
élitaire on a la version du café d'à
côté où vous savez on entend dire
parfois je ne suis pas raciste mais
trois petits points parfois même on en
rigole et puis il ya celle de maquereau
est celle de beaucoup de ceux et celles
qui se présente aujourd'hui comme
intellectuel d'ailleurs qu'ils se font
du beurre sur le dos des musulmans des
musulmanes qui nous explique avec des
précautions langagière
qu'on s'entende bien nous n'accusons pas
tous les musulmans toutes les musulmanes
l'essentiel des musulmans des musulmans
pratiquent leur religion dans le respect
de la laïcité des règles républicaines
mais et puis se déverse évidemment des
choses qui sont totalement inaudibles
parce que totalement incompréhensible
ces précautions l'engager en réalité
cache autre chose mais c'est pas nouveau
dans l'histoire de france
très peu de remontées très très loin en
1983 tournant de la rigueur des
problèmes économiques majeures ce profil
des grèves massives ont lieu dans les
entreprises de l'automobile renault
talbot citroën et on entend à l'époque
mauroy gaston defferre nous dire dire
dans les médias
paris match et qu'on pris le relais les
services secrets et ira bien de la libye
sont derrière ces ouvriers ces ouvrières
syndiqués syndicalistes qui manifestent
et ça va être relayée cette mainmise des
intégristes venant de l'extérieur et ses
acteurs on a aujourd'hui le même
discours ni ce qui nous est resservie
encore aujourd'hui par macro alors qu'on
a comme ça a été dit par olivier le cour
grandmaison à juste titre on a
aujourd'hui une situation de crise
multiple
qui se traduit finalement par une crise
de sens beaucoup de personnes se
demandent où va t-on dans la crise
actuelle et face à cette crise de sens
et bien le gouvernement ne trouve rien
de mieux que pour faire du ciment social
a montré du doigt des boucs émissaires
aujourd'hui les musulmans et les
musulmanes de ce prix là je le dis avec
beaucoup de sincérité qu'on s'entende
bien ceux et celles qui ont écouté mâcon
et qui sont de confession ou de culture
musulmane ont été particulièrement
blessée
je ne pas pas en leur nom je n'ai
évidemment pas la légitimité mais je
peux vous assurer que les retours que
nous avons sont s'étendre là c'est qu'au
bout d'un moment ça commence à bien
faire pour deux raisons très simples
c'est qu'au détour du coc vide on a pu
voir qui est lé dernier de cordée
on a pu voir ce qui tenait entre
guillemets la france dans son
fonctionnement du quotidien vous savez
ceux et celles qui se lève très tôt le
matin qui se couche très tard le soir
qu'on désert totalement est découpée
dans la journée qu'ils sont très très
mal payés pour les boulots les plus
difficiles et qui pourtant beaucoup
d'entre eux sont des immigrés ou des
enfants d'immigrés et pour certains
d'entre eux de confession musulman de
confession musulmane
eh bien ce sont ses biens les causes et
qui ont payé très cher la facture est
compris en terme de mortalité de
surmortalité on le vend cen sad hill on
le voit dans ma ville argenteuil
dans beaucoup de villes populaires et
compris actuellement l'insee vient de
sortir des chiffres ou très clairement
c'est dix fois trois fois plus de
personnes issues de l'immigration qui
sont mortes du comique que la population
majoritaire et bien si encore cela qu'on
montre du doigt au regard de leur
religiosité
ça commence à bouger raconte aux propos
qui ont été tenus par madame juste
précédemment j'hallucine
c'est qu'il faut être aujourd'hui le
faire démonstration que ton compte quand
on est athée ou agnostique sur la place
publique on a du mal à vivre mais de
quoi parle-t-on
mais dans quel délire sommes-nous ça
qu'aujourd'hui on crée des fantasmes et
des peurs et c'est l'objet justement de
l'islamophobie pour ne pas créer d un
certain nombre de questions sociales de
ce point de vue là c'est évidemment une
diversion et l'autre aspect c'est que ça
s'appuie évidemment sur un racisme
structurel un racisme distillées dans
toutes les institutions
c'est l'objet d'ailleurs de notre livre
raciste peu de france écrit avec
plusieurs contributeurs est
contributrice alors à l'ags ok merci
j'avais très hâte de répondre à tout
cela alors très bien d'abord bien
entendu plusieurs choses notamment qui
jour une diversion une version la crise
sociale la crise sanitaire
j'aimerais juste rappeler à ces
messieurs que l'état ne se résume pas en
fait à bercy ou à au ministère de la
santé président de la république a tenu
son discours sur le séparatisme terme
que j'apprécie par ailleurs parce qu'il
pour le coup il mettait en relief le
caractère séditieux en fait du problème
dont on parle caractère séditieux
d'ailleurs qu'on retrouve dans le
mouvement qui a été fondée par monsieur
slaouti s'appelant rosa parks qui avait
appelé à un retrait massif des personnes
issues de l'immigration pendant une
journée et a montré ce que à quoi ça
ressemblait que de vivre selon ses
propres lois
si cela n'est pas du séparatisme je veux
bien que l'on me dise ce que c'était
ensuite le président de la république
est donc parti aujourd'hui par exemple à
la roya pour voir les sinistrés il est
allé aussi à l'hôpital rothschild etc
etc
donc on peut ouvrir plusieurs fronts et
et traiter tous les problèmes à la fois
sans qu'à chaque fois je pense que les
personnes qui crie à la diversion sont
justement celles qui utilisent la crise
sanitaire et économique pour que l'on
traite pas du problème du séparatisme
maintenant je ne voulais pas avoir de
conversation voilà directes entre nous
mais si vous y tenez j'ai pu jeter un
coup d'oeil aux livres dont il est
question et dont on fait la promo je
suis très triste de ne pas avoir pu le
lire qu'il ne sort que demain pareil par
contre j'ai pu jeter un coup d'oeil au
sommaire et surprise pas de mention au
racisme intracommunautaire la théophanie
qui existe un on a vu mis là on a pu les
voir zineb el rhazoui que je suppose qui
je suppose doit être quelqu'un dont on
ne devrait pas cité le nom ici on le
voit aussi moi personnellement en tant
que maghrébine athée je le vois
régulièrement
je peux citer des cas vu que le ressenti
et ceux qui crient mais qui vont se
valeurs de savoir
moi j'ai déjà été agressée rue de la
guillotière à lyon parce que je suis
mais une cigarette pendant le ramadan je
ne vois pas ces messieurs en parler dans
l'eure
vivre les actes christianophobes et je
n'aime pas ce mot phobie se multiplient
en france ce n'est pas traitée dans le
livre landisacq l'antisémitisme
bizarrement on le traite en le mettant
en parallèle avec l'anti sionisme
aucune mention à l'arabophobie mais on
parle par contre d'islamophobie qui
assimile les musulmans tous les arabes
al islam
visiblement ce sont ces messieurs c'est
moi qui fantasme moi je ne suis pas
traité dans ce livre alors que je suis
victime de discrimination aussi donc
fantasme ou pas je vous je les
laisserais répondre maintenant je finis
très rapidement il y a un sentiment
effectivement de discrimination moi
j'accuse les personnes qui justement le
dénonce en parlant au nom des musulmans
qui en dix ans juste après je ne le
prétend pas c'est eux qui créent ce
sentiment ce travail de sape fait le
travail de la visibilité par la
victimisation et c'est l'extrême gauche
qui en est responsable aujourd'hui car
moi les retours que j'ai eu c'est enfin
on sera débarrassé des pros polygamie
qui le revendique aujourd'hui même en
attaquant la ministre marlène schiappa
sur les réseaux sociaux de ceux qui
disent la l'excision ce n'est pas grave
et j'en passe minoritaires oui mais il
faut s'en débarrasse alors qui veut
répondre mars à outils ou olivier le
cour grandmaison
main oui non mais très rapidement parce
que ça mérite pas qu'on développe outre
mesure concernera passe pas comme nous
avons papier seulement les personnes de
l'immigration à ne pas aller travailler
à se mettre en garde ce jour là avaient
toutes les personnes qui s'opposent au
racisme structurel dans ce pays là donc
arrêtez les caricatures et deuxièmement
vous êtes dit fini tout allant de la
laïcité ça m'inquiète beaucoup je n'ai
pas de laïcité comme un comme un point
d'équilibré city n'a jamais été
historiquement un point d'équilibré
s'il fallait le résumé c'est d'abord et
avant tout quasiment seulement la
neutralité de l'état et des
représentants de l'état
c'est pas un point d'équilibré entre les
croyants et les non croyants et c'est
vraiment parce que vous modifiez le
logiciel de la laïcité qu'on a
régulièrement des problèmes avec cette
question là je tiens le dire ici tous et
toutes celles qui demandent plus
d'égalité tous contre tous les racismes
demande aussi l'application de la
laïcité dans sa version originelle et
évidemment nous vous en faisons partie
quant à ce qui est du livre on s'excuse
madame d'avoir pas pris contact avec
vous pour que vous puissiez nous
raconter vos déboires personnels autour
de cette cigarette fumée pendant la cote
de ramadan par contre je vais vous
rassurer madame il est question dans ce
livre et je vous invite donc à le lire à
parler y compris des contradictions
internes y compris parfois du racisme
inter communautaires parce qu'ils en
effet c'est une réalité
vous savez il est fait par un certain
nombre d'universitaires de militants de
les deux tiers d'entre eux sont racisées
on le souhaitait évidemment mais
évidemment vous allez voir il ya aussi
des contradictions
il ya de la polémique à l'intérieur
c'est un livre vivant c'est un livre pas
simplement d'intellectuels perché ce
sont des livres qui ont une approche
extrêmement scientifique des sujets
qu'ils abordent nous nous donnons des
chiffres là où vous vous nous donnez
strictement aucun effet puisque vous
parlez drame tshikapa
juste un mot parce que ça nous fait rire
elle a osé quand même se refait mal en
pis y'a pas sur ce qu'on appelait les
certificat de virginité
on est tous allés fouiller il n'y a
aucun chiffre aucun chiffre ni officiel
ni officieux sur le nombre de certificat
de virginité pire que ça
les médecins gynécologues et parfois qui
sont responsables de haut niveau de
l'état sur les questions d'égalité nous
disent que c'est une supercherie absolue
concrètement les médecins quand ils ont
été amenés à le faire dans des cas les
sims est quasiment totalement
anecdotique du rapporté au nombre
c'est simplement un bout de papier c'est
à dire qu' à aucun examen de la personne
physiologique biologique de l'hymen en
quoi que ce soit c'est juste un bout de
papier
donc faut arrêter les délires faut
arrêter d'attiser les peurs vous en
faites partie
mieux que ça vous gagnez votre salaire
sur les peurs et les haines et sur
l'islamophobie en particulier c'est
dommage c'est grave bernard godard
un mot sur pour finir avec la laïcité
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec avec
la lecture qu'on a qu'on a donnée le
président de la république dans le
discours que je viens de donges viennent
vous passez un extrait et quand il parle
de de tolérance religieuse de neutralité
de l'état date air il fait allusion
faite à l'interdiction qui est faite à
l'état de choisir entre les religions
de préférer les unes ou de rejeter les
autres et puis aussi évidemment
l'interdiction de persécuter les
croyants pour leurs croyances
est ce que c'est bien ça la laïcité en
france depuis depuis 1905 ça n'est pas
seulement la loi de 1905 qui en a eu
plusieurs
mais peu importe d'abord la laïcité
c'est surtout pas la tolérance
religieuse
la tolérance c'est quand vous admettez
par exemple il ya une région majoritaire
et que vous autorisez d'autres à exister
à côté d'elle donc la tolérance s'est
passé assez la neutralité c'est à dire
le train ils n'ont pas forcément est
plus distant mais d'avoir une certaine
commandes y ait une certaine distance
l'état avec les religions ne leur
permette leur expression dans le cas de
l'ordre public et c'est tout simple ce
sont des principes vraiment très simple
à la laïcité c'est pas la laïcité bon
alors l'album 105 vous faites bien de
l'évoquer il ya eu une évolution c'est
entre 1905 et les années 50-60 on va
dire il ya eu quand même une bataille
puisque c'était quand même avant tout
une lutte contre l'église et contre le
cléricalisme et à partir des années 60
et surtout après les pratiquants 2 on a
eu quand même une autre période qui est
que pose que jean-paul l'aimais et
d'autres définissent comme étant une
laïcité de reconnaissance qui fait
pousser des hauts cris au laïka entre
guillemets mais c'est vrai que
maintenant on a vis-à-vis dès religions
une position complètement différente
mais c'est ça qui est important
et je ne crois pas que ce soit une
histoire de tolérance par rapport à
telle ou telle religion les religions
notifie l'état ne définit pas si tel ou
tel
confessions et tu ne replonge donc pas
d'été mal jéhovah n'étaient pas reconnus
en fin dé n'existait pas si vous voulez
dans la loi dans le sens où il n'avait
pas de risque et administratives parce
qu'on ne leur permettait pas d'exister
comme religion et pas à partir de 2001
il doit exister
et puis ça peut changer pour une autre
et donc c'est pas du tout ça la laïcité
ont fait une pause et on repense des
belges juste après le secteur de
l'immobilier a n'a pas été épargnés par
les mesures sanitaires d'urgence mis en
place par le gouvernement les banques
aujourd'hui donc on sait qu'elles vont
un peu coupé les robinets et si elle
coupe les robinets ça va être un petit
peu plus compliqué pour l'immobilier
l'immobilier haut de gamme était la
valeur refuge par excellence c'est le
cas qui a plus de 75 ans a priori
l'achète pas un appartement il le vent
et comme il aura pas beaucoup de
retraite
il est assez probable qu'ils soient
obligés de vendre son actif pour
continuer à vivre
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui fait que vous allez avoir une baisse
des prix dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
revanche des campagnes contre les villes
parce que les villes souffrent
globalement tout le marché comme dit
olivier doit devenir plus raisonnable
les acquéreurs vont être plus sélectifs
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et la préparer il
ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter vert à 30% de son
pub pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux il
ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec bernard godard
avec omar slaouti à la oukili olivier le
cour grandmaison
va pour la laïcité on y reviendra
peut-être mais je rappelle que le au
départ ce projet de loi c'était contre
le séparatisme et précis plus
précisément contre le séparatisme
islamistes est ce que est ce qu'il ya un
problème de séparatisme est ce que 2 est
ce que le mot était bien choisie est ce
que est ce qu'il n'ya que les islamistes
radicaux qui voudraient faire du
séparatisme sais ce que c'est propre à
d'autres religions on a cité aussi les
chrétiens évangélistes
alors olivier le cour grandmaison le
cible le séparatisme en tant que telle
qu'est ce que ça vous qu'est-ce que vous
ça vous inspire
et est-ce qu'il ya des gens je le
rappelle dans la définition qui a été
donné par le gouvernement sont
séparatistes ceux qui veulent se séparer
de lait des lois de la république et et
vivre selon d'autres lois
en fait elle ce qu'on a ça en france tu
vois je voudrais rapidement répondre à
la journaliste précédente sur sur le
livre que nous avons dirigé omar slaouti
et moi même je suis très heureux de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui visiblement a
la science infuse et qui en se
contentant simplement de la lecture du
sommaire d'un ouvrage est capable de
déterminer son contenu est en fait
madame vous ne jugez pas du contenu des
ouvrages au sens propre du terme vous
préjugez par ailleurs une remarque
incidente
et puisque vous êtes visiblement
mobiliser contre tous les racismes je
suis tout à fait surpris que
relativement aux déclarations d'eric
zemmour causeur accueille sur son site
un article prenant la défense de zemmour
et considérant qu' au-delà de ces
déclarations lui doit être défendue en
matière de lutte contre le racisme
il me semble que causeur n'a vraiment
pas de leçons à nous donner
vous êtes pris là dans des
contradictions qui sont évidemment les
vôtres et je voulais laisser bout les
abandonne avec plaisir sur la question
du séparatisme que des terroristes
islamistes est un projet séparatiste
assurément
la question est de savoir quelle est la
menace réelle de ce point de vue-là il
me semble qu'on a affaire là aussi et là
encore une construction à la fois
politiques médiatiques parfois soutenues
par des travaux universitaires pour
l'essentiel le séparatisme n'existe pas
à proprement parler dans la société
française que vous pourrez même renversé
au fond de la proposition dans un des
passages du discours d' emmanuel macron
il a rappelé quelques au fond la
république avait une responsabilité dans
le surgissement en france de ce qu'il a
appelé les ghettos ou de ce que d'autres
appellent légué les quartiers perdus ou
prétendument conquis et je crois que
s'il ya un séparatisme ou en tout cas
des politiques publiques qui favorise le
séparatisme ce sont bien ces politiques
publiques d'abandon des services publics
d'abandon des écoles de rétractation des
services publics et rappeler par exemple
que la seine-saint-denis le 9-3 comme on
dit est un des départements français les
plus pauvres en métropole les plus
pauvres que je sache des millions pour
ne pas dire des milliards ont été
accordés aux entreprises à la suite de
la crise économique et sociale que nous
connaissons et sanitaires je n'ai pas à
vous dire que des milliards ou en tout
cas des centaines de millions étaient
réservées aux 9,3 pour lutter
effectivement contre ce qui relève d'une
d'un abandon de ces quartiers
et c'est effectivement emmanuel macron a
en partie raison
c'est cet abandon qui permet à certains
à une toute petite minorité de prospérer
mais de ce point de vue là là aussi il a
encore force et la setil de constater
que les moyens de lutter contre cet
abandon dans le discours emmanuel macron
et beaucoup de beaucoup d'observateurs
et d'analystes l'ont constaté ces moyens
sont absolument dérisoires pour ne pas
dire inexistants et là où qui lie il ya
un problème de séparatisme pour vous et
je me dis je vais aussi devoir arrêter
vous qui m'a fait l'honneur
voilà de m'envoyer plusieurs petites
punchline je n'ai pas pu juger de ce que
contenait le livre j'ai même reconnu au
tout début ne pas l'avoir lu et le
regretter parce que j'aurais aimé vous
confronter après l'avoir dit
j'ai créé juger des billets étant donné
le la deuxième partie et les chapitres
qui énonce et les formes de racisme je
ne voyais pas d'autres formes de racisme
que je trouve pro qui je trouve prospère
au delà de ça vous parler d'eric zemmour
ça tombe très bien je ne suis pas
content je représente le bal réseau
ginko ouvrage je soutiens non j'ai dit
j'ai des billets des billets donc les
biais c'est à dire ce qu'on met les
grandes lignes puis ce qui va être dans
les petites pages parce que c'est pas
très intéressant et que je pense moi est
aussi intéressant que tout le reste
laissez moi finir merci je ne vous ai
pas interrompu ne leur fait plus donc
causeur défend eric zemmour sa liberté
d'expression autant que moi je défends
le droit d'être ici en train de vous
parler alors que vous pouvez être
considérés comme des pestiférés par
d'autres camps et je suis pour la le
libéralisme le plus absolu quand il
s'agit du marché des idées contre le le
le la censure autant que je le peux et
je suis très très fier d'appartenir à un
magazine qui donne autant la parole à
des personnes d'extrême gauche comme vos
amis de la france insoumise et du npa
que de chez eux moore du r'n b femme qui
n'aime pas les hommes
je m'en fiche je n'en n'ai rien à faire
et ça me convient très bien
séparatisme oui je pense qu'il ya un
séparatisme monsieur thaddée nick nous
avons plusieurs cas de d'infraction à la
laïcité qui remonte au ministère de
l'éducation nationale nous avons
plusieurs cas d'école qui endoctrinent
des enfants notamment le centre des
lumières par exemple qui a été fermé à
sainte afin de nous il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça
nous avons des problèmes de livres qui
sont vendus alors qu'ils sont interdits
par exemple comment apprendre le tao
chine aux enfants sont interdits on a
encore des demandeurs qui achètent ça
pour enseigner quoi aux mineurs nous
avons un problème de séparatisme quand
on exige de jeunes petites filles qui
vont à l'école de portée des petits
fiable pour aller dans des caves de
bicol 2
contrat non ce n'est pas le nombre qui
compte c'est la protection de tous voilà
et agité l'islamophobie et qui n'est
autre que un prétexte pour ne pas
s'attaquer à tout cela ne doit pas
fonctionner et je pense que les pouvoirs
publics ne doivent pas céder là dessus
ensuite dernière chose ma définition de
la laïcité j'ai été étonné d'entendre
que je la déployait jamais je n'ai
prétendu l'aide la dévoyer j'ai juste
revendiquer l'égalité en droits entre
les non croyants et les croyantes c'est
à dire on les chrétiens ou peu importe
on droit de convertir m prosélyte de
critiquer les religions et des convertir
rappelez moi enfin corrigez moi si j'ai
tort autre chose neutralité de l'état
oui séparation des églises et de l'état
oui mais liberté de conscience
depuis quand c'est la neutralité la
laïcité ça n'a aucun sens je ne
comprends pas comment on peut m'accuser
de dévoyer la laïcité ny je crois que
j'ai fini merci beaucoup
la neutralité c'est la neutralité de
l'état évidemment ça n'est pas les ailes
la neutralité des individualistes affres
et laïque
ce ne sont ni dû encore une fois bien
sur quoi vous étiez au quand vous étiez
au ministère de l'intérieur
est ce qu'il y avait tout ce dont on
parle est là ou qu'il y ait ce que ça
existait bien sûr c'est à dire toutes
les questions qui te donnes entonné les
tensions de plus en plus forte qui se
sont posés autour de l'islam ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
c'était déjà on va dire que jusqu'en la
carte ou 19 cents pendant excusez-moi si
si si jusqu'en 1995 96 et ça commençait
à monter surtout à partir des années
2000 alors il faut bien savoir que par
rapport à l'islamophobie et dame madame
je vous fais remarquer que moi je
n'étais pas du tout en tenant par
exemple de la de l'islamophobie puisque
quand en 2009 j'étais où on m'a demandé
de préparer quelque chose pour la
recension des actes anti-musulmans de
matignon avait transmis
le mot islamophobie jeudi leur
islamophobie c'est pas tellement habile
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'il se
trouve que l'islamophobie le comité
contre l'islamophobie avait mis au
centre de son action
la lutte contre l'islamophobie et a donc
comme si l'état est accusé d'être
islamophobe
ça pose un peu un problème ensuite de
dire est prêt recension des actes
islamophobes
donc c'était la raison je dirais que
effectivement j'étais assez réticents
pour différentes raisons que je vais pas
expliquer ici mais parce que non ça
prendrait beaucoup de temps mais je
pense que j'étais assez ça nos phobies
la racisation des musulmans je pensais
qu'à l'époque on pouvait encore
effectivement distinguer tous et tous
ses registres se trouve que depuis
effectivement les attentats et depuis
les dérives qui sont intervenus on a
quand même un pan entier de l'opinion
qui plus largement s'est exprimé en des
termes on va dire je dis cela mot frog
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ce qui
était cantonné au journal causeur par
exemple à certains mouvements
identitaires d'extrême droite
bon c'était des gens qui étaient très
présents il y avait des actes
effectivement dans la droite dure qui
était assez caractéristique
d'islamophobie
mais après c'est la dérive c'est la
dérive et là on peut parler un petit peu
de racisation là le terme est beaucoup
plus adéquat je pense aujourd'hui je
pense que ces défis d importants c'est à
dire que dans le fond le printemps
républicain et maintenant je prends
l'exemple de 7,7
cette instance est cette association bon
ce sont des gens qui n'étaient pas donc
je connais certains qui n'étaient pas du
tout
tenant ni de l'est at elle disait moblin
mais qui n'était pas islamophobe bon et
là on a un problème
alors c'est vrai que par exemple je
crois que le présent macro n'est pas du
tout et ça vole à mon avis pas du tout 1
mais si vous voulez ils succombent aux
sirènes si vous voulez d'un certain
nombre de mouvements qui théorisent de
plus en plus sur cette radicalisation de
l'islam et sur le fait que tous les
musulmans un moment vont être comptable
de 7 à cette radicalisation et sont
susceptibles de tomber dans le piège
cette radicalisation
et ça je trouve que c'est assez
dangereux omar slaouti
oui je crois que il ya des mots qui
cache en réalité dévêtue on est passé de
communautarisme un séparatisme et vous
nous l'avait dit en début d'émission de
séparatisme avec une oie estampillé
défense de la laïcité et des libertés
publiques les publics est et ses
médailles en un mot on parle de la même
chose derrière des mots on parle d'une
chose bien précises c'est que il y
aurait dans notre pays des personnes
musulmanes en l'occurrence parce qu'on
disait des séparatistes mais très
rapidement la focale s'est resserrée
uniquement sur l'islam et les musulmans
et les musulmanes qui aurait décidé dans
un projet politique de faire sécession
parce que le séparatisme ne tient pas
debout c'est ça le séparatisme basques
catalans corps on a connu ça et compris
parfois même avec une branche r b voilà
comme on attise des peurs et là ce qui
est à l'ordre du jour c'est vraiment
cela est donc une question se pose où
sont les chiffres
où sont les études de quoi parle-t-on où
sont ils un exemple monsieur m'a conduit
dans son discours il y a des enfants de
3 ans qui ne sont pas scolarisés et
donne le chiffre de 50 milles il précise
aussitôt que la moitié d'entre eux sont
pas scolarisés pour des raisons
médicales
donc la fourchette se réduit environ
25000 et sur ses vingt-cinq mille ha
nous ne savons pas du tout qui est
musulman qui n'est pas musulman
quand bien même sans réel impact qu'est
ce qu'il ya derrière qu'on ne sait rien
par contre nous disons à monsieur macro
qui a décidé donc dans ce futur projet
nos a priori de scolariser tous les
enfants de 3 ans nous disons non
monsieur macro que les enfants de moins
de 3 ans sont treize fois plus
scolarisés à l'échelle nationale qu'en
seine saint denis pour des raisons
financières et de casse des services
publics
or nous savons que plutôt commence la
scolarisation mieux meilleur et la
réussite scolaire or nous demandons-nous
plus de services publics plus d'école
plus d'hôpitaux plus en l'occurrence ici
de les animations autrement dit ce qui
se passe c'est au lieu de mettre la
focale sur la question des inégalités
sociales qui structurent se paie la
montre du doigt certaines populations
avec en plus une méprise totalement
absolue derrière couple au tarissement
qu'on se trompe pas s'il ya en effet des
quartiers où la population est
majoritairement noirs
arabes turcs musulmans musulmane ou de
culture musulmans musulmane c'est en
effet une réalité c'est ce que valls a
osé appeler des territoires qui
relèverait de l'apartheid
après celle qu'il a lui-même contribué à
construire de la même manière macro
continue en creusant les inégalités
sociales les gens vont se lâcher
là où le donc c'est moins cher là où
évidemment le mètre carré le moins cher
il se retrouve évidemment dans cet
endroit là mais qu'on s'entende bien
c'est pas du communautarisme c'est une
communautarisation forcer les personnes
qui se retrouvent dans ces quartiers-là
subissent la réalité cette ségrégation
socio spatiales on a même envie de dire
ratio socio-spatiales parce
qu'évidemment ils vont s'y retrouver
beaucoup plus que les autres parce que
les noirs les arabes du fait du racisme
structurel dans ce pays là dont on sait
jamais des faits depuis la colonisation
ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas de
rupture il ya des continuités et des
ruptures ans est à thala mais on a
évidemment une islamophobie structure
dans spider alors maintenant que la
journaliste qui parle de pudeur de
causeur de ne comprennent pas ce que
c'est que la laïcité qui est qu'elle se
rend celle ci beaucoup plus simple
qu'elle a eue au texte et puis qu'elle
se fasse sa propre idée mais faut
arrêter de dire tout et n'importe quoi
et encore une fois ne disons pas qu'il
n'ya pas ici et là des personnes qui
pourraient avoir un projet politique
séparatiste
évidemment de la même manière je tiens à
rappeler puisque quand même la mosquée
omar récemment des flics des gendarmes
sont intervenus
c'est très récent ont tout saccagé des
enfants étaient en train de lire en
train d'apprendre l'arabe
ils ont été traumatisés finalement
qu'est ce qu'on reproche à cette mosquée
est bien un problème de mise aux normes
au niveau incendie voilà ce à quoi mène
évidemment les propos de maintenance de
ce point de vue là je le dis très
ouvertement macron tient des propos
islamophobes dont les conséquences sont
évidemment islamophobe et si on voudrait
élargir le spectre il y a des centaines
d'églises ou ont fait la baisse en latin
où on a des traditionalistes chrétiens
qui sont des héritiers de monseigneur
lefebvre qu'on n'embête pas du tout les
mêmes qui ont manifesté contre la loi p
m
les 80 députés est ce qu'on aura souvent
de l air anciennement ump qui se sont
mobilisés contre le fait qu'on parle de
la question du genre dans les programmes
scolaires de sciences de la vie la terre
en première es en première littéraire
littéraire est-ce que de cela causeur en
parle pas du tout on focalise surtout
sur les mains et évidemment c'est ça le
problème
alors je vous rappelle que je suis des
débats ça n'est pas causeur mais il est
mais le projet de loi du gouvernement
est il justement on l'a suffisamment dit
le nom a changé c'est un projet de loi
pour renforcer la laïcité et les
principes républicains et alors là je me
tourne vers olivier le cour grandmaison
puisque vous enseignez à la fois les
sciences politiques et la philosophie
politique
c'est quoi ces fameux c'est quoi ces
fameuses ces fameux ray principes
républicains
ou plutôt où ces valeurs républicaines
puisque c'est selon les cas on va parler
de valeurs républicaines ou de principes
républicains
mais on nous dit jamais clairement de
quoi il s'agit qu'est ce que c'est les
principes républicains et qu'est ce que
c'est les valeurs républicaines
fondamentalement on pourrait hélas chose
est inscrite au fronton d'un certain de
bâtiments publics pour ne pas dire de
tous les bâtiments publics
liberté égalité fraternité c'est un
principe fondamental de la république et
park
par ailleurs sont des principes
fondamentaux de la république bien sûr
l'ensemble des textes fondateurs et en
particulier les déclarations des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen rappeler
simplement ceci que ce qui est en jeu là
ce n'est pas fondamentalement me
semble-t-il la remise en cause des
principes républicains
en tout cas pas par celles et ceux qui
sont désignés comme étant supposément
celles et ceux qui travaillent au
séparatisme ce qui est constaté
faut-il le rappeler notamment par celui
qui a pendant très longtemps été le
défenseur des droits jacques toubon dans
les fonctions se sont achevés cet été et
qui dans son dernier rapport rappelle et
utilise les catégories que nous sommes
un certain nombre d'universitaires et de
chercheurs a utilisé à savoir la
catégorie de racisme systémique de
discrimination systémique d' approche
intersectionnelle et au delà de ces
concepts et de ces catégories qui font
l'objet de débats et d'études tout à
fait précise en france et à l'étranger
le rapport de jacques toubon défenseur
des droits donc se concluait sur ceux ci
que la somme de ses discrimination
systémique qui a fait effectivement
notamment et les populations racisées et
les immigrés et les héritiers de
l'immigration coloniale et postcoloniale
contribuent très fortement à remettre en
cause ce qu'il appelait au fond le pacte
républicain ce que pour beaucoup
d'autres appellent ainsi et au fond ce
qui était constaté c'est que les
principes républicains n'étaient pas
effective dans nombre de quartiers
j'ai reprendrait aussi cette expression
et cette formule que j'aime beaucoup de
robert badinter qui disait la france et
le pays de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme la france n'est pas le pays des
droits de l'homme et on pourrait dire
aussi que la france est certes le pays
des principes républicains mais que la
france n'est pas encore hélas ce pays où
ces principes sont effectifs la preuve
la situation où les situations qui sont
faites à l'ensemble des populations et
racisées et à l'ensemble des populations
qui vivent dans les quartiers populaires
et qui à l'évidence sont victimes donc
de discrimination systémique qui
remettent en cause ses principes la
liberté l'égalité et bien sûr la
fraternité parce que ils sont
stigmatisés et dans le discours une des
valets le maquereau relativement au
séparatisme et c'est un saut qualitatif
et langagier et politiques qui me paraît
très important
ils sont désignés comme faisant peser
une menace existentielle sur l'unité
nationale et l'unité républicaine et de
l'or qu'on les désigne un si grand est
le risque effectivement de légitimer
d'une part des discours d'une extrême
violence politique et symbolique et
au-delà de ces discours de justifier et
de légitimer hélas aussi des pratiques
discriminatoires plus grave encore à la
rencontre aller au quilit entendu non je
voulais savoir quel était votre réaction
à la fois aux propos d'olivier le cour
grandmaison
ou simplement à la question que j'avais
posées concernant ce renforcement des
principes républicains et à savoir
lesquels puisque on connaît la loi la
loi tout le monde doit la respecter mais
les principes républicains les valeurs
républicaines
on est libre d'y adhérer ou pas et de
l'est et de le faire de façon très
relative on peut être à fond pour la
liberté économique par exemple pas du
tout pour la liberté économique
on a le droit de fraterniser comme on en
a envie
voilà c'est l'important c'est de
respecter la loi
donc vous donne la parole merci je ne
pense pas que respecter la loi suffit à
faire nation est justement ce qui est à
dénoncer
de plus en plus c'est cette alliance
entre l'extrême gauche et ceux qu'on
appelle les s'appelait séparatiste
islamiste qui oeuvrent tous les deux
avec chacun ses moyens propres les uns
nourrissent des autres avec une
impression d'endoctrinement leur servent
de gourou pour induire en eux un
sentiment de victimisation accrue parce
que une discrimination c'est une chose
mais faire croire à quelqu'un que l'état
entier la nation entière et contre lui
que quoi qu'il arrive il n'arrivera
jamais à rien parce que de toutes les
façons il est condamné à être le petit
esclave de la nation bien sûr que ça ne
peut induire que le chaos
et ce qui est drôle c'est qu'après on
les applaudit on leur dit c'est bien
c'est de l'insurrection
l'évolutionnisme casser tout péter tout
brûler tout voilà non moi je dis qu'il y
avait effectivement des discriminations
c'est tout laisse aussi dans toutes les
sociétés il ya des discriminations
elle concerne les gens selon que ce soit
la couleur de peau ça peut aussi être
vis-à-vis du statut social et c'est ce
que je dénonce par contre c'est ce
qu'ils revendiquent en fait une
légitimité pour combattre ces
discriminations et qui propose de
dissoudre en fait le ciment qui soude
une nation
pour verser un rapport de domination
qu'ils ont participé à grossir et à
fantasmer pour lutter contre tout ce qui
est rapport à la discrimination dans un
pays qui a un arsenal judiciaire des
plus développés pour la lutte contre le
racisme
je pense qu'il faut au contraire
favoriser l'égalité des chances par le
fait de donner une éducation égale à
tout le monde et ça commence aussi par
ne pas insulter les gens en les appelant
dé racisées qui n'est pour moi rien
d'autre que le pendant de termes que je
ne nommerai pas et que l'on utilisait au
temps des colonies racisées qu'est ce
que cela veut dire
moi je ne suis pas une racisées je suis
quelqu'un qui s'en sort qui va continuer
de s'en sortir qui se battra et
contrairement à ce que monsieur slaouti
dit je ne me fais pas de l'argent sur le
dos des musulmans je n'en gagne pas
c'est mon père qui me il est au maroc
vous pourrez lui le traiter
d'islamophobe du cry 5 fois par jour et
il soutient la liberté de conscience
contrairement à ceux qui osent m'appeler
une racisées et hameaux condamné à être
de culture musulmane en biologie dans
une roue une religion et donc en rendant
les citoyens entre inégaux selon donc il
la culture dont ils sont issus quand
vous êtes maghrébins vous n'avez pas le
droit de naître à thé comme jean paul
jean pierre et tous les autres non on va
vous refusez une révolution qui a mené à
une loi incroyable qui a duré pendant
300 ans
parce que vous êtes vous vous appelez
mohamed 1 et on va vous dire que de
toutes les façons quoi que vous fassiez
vous êtes condamné à l'échec
autre chose vous avez un passé très très
vite
monseigneur je ne sais plus qu un plus
qui excusez moi loi anti pma je vous
rappelle que les islamistes ont
manifesté ismahane chouder était avec
eux pour la manif pour tous et que les
islamistes aussi était contre la paix
mais je me vois pas de quoi on me parle
autre chose je rappelle qu'aucune loi
même avec ce projet contre le
séparatisme
aucune loi ne vise les east les
musulmans même désiste
amy est en fait finalement nommément à
chaque fois qu'on y temps par exemple le
même la neutralité aux sous traitants du
service public
cette neutralité concernera tous les
signes religieux philosophiques et
politiques
quand on va s'attaquer à l'excision ou
quand on va s'attaquer au certificat de
virginité
on ne vise pas non plus des musulmans
pour le coup on protège les femmes
monsieur comment pouvez-vous me dire les
médecins ont finalement répondu qu' il
ne s'agissait que de petits papiers
signés mais qui l'humiliation n'y a même
pas besoin d'aller fouiller entre les
jambes des femmes
c'est une humiliation délivre un
certificat de virginité qu'est ce que
cela signifie qu'une femme doit être
vierge d'abord un ça c'est déjà du
sexisme ordinaire comme vous le dites et
dont vous êtes coupable autre chose
alors non non dernière chance
excusez moi très vite fait j'arrête
excuses je vous en supplie il faut que
je buvais jacques toubon je ne connais
aucun de ces rapports nous avons appris
dernièrement qu'il était conseillé par
un espèce de conseil obscur qui étaient
eux à 100% indigéniste s'il était juge
j'aurais demandé à ce qu'on ouvre
absolument tous les cas qu'il a traité
parce que cela signifie qu'il avait un
billet parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
conseillé par la nation mais par un
mouvement politique séparatiste alors
dernier mot bernard godard et omar
slaouti mission française ou 30 secondes
chacun
oui concernant le séparatisme l'a pas
dit mais c'est vrai que bon à force de
focaliser sur une espèce de projets
c'est du complotisme à caen par
d'islamisme je vais pas défendre des
islamistes à tout accord medisys
islamiste cette focalisation voyez vous
vous ne parlez certificat de virginité
vous parlez de la pudeur voyez chose
comme ça c'est le patriarcat si on parle
de plein de phénomènes de société qu il
ya dans toutes les sociétés pas
seulement musulmane effectivement cessé
très présent alors là vous citez bon on
peut citer un mouvement plutôt le
fondamentalisme musulman pour choisir
les mots comment comme on doit le dire
1 le forez pour les musulmans c'est vrai
qu'ils la jouent un rôle et c'est vrai
qu'un mouvement qu'on nous ment tablir
depuis les années 80 a joué un rôle de
rupture de lien social
moi je préfère le mot de rupture de
l'aide sociale plutôt que c'était
séparatisme on n'a jamais dit du bout
mantha bien que c'était un mouvement
séparatiste et pourtant c'est ce qui
effectivement ce qu'il prône depuis une
trentaine d'années et c'est vrai que le
vrai danger c'est par rapport au monde
en salle un fils qui se sert de ces
moments patriarcaux ces deux de toutes
ces cct spéciale d'un largage et je
défends un peu les islamistes dans le
sens encore c'est vrai qu'il ya un
projet politique qui est vraiment mal en
point parce que les islamistes dans le
monde arabe
excusez moi mais ils sont pas ils sont
pas vraiment à la fête que ce soit en
syrie que ce soit en libye où que ce
soit dans d'autres centres ou en égypte
ou tout simplement
donc du coup il faut nommer les choses
donc correctement et peut-être on pourra
y voir plus clair
bach saouti de phrases que les missions
déjà terminé deux phrases à l'autre mais
bien sûr non mais très simplement qu'on
le veuille ou pas à la société de la
même manière qu'elle est jean rey et
qu'elle se structurer compris au regard
du genre dans tous les espaces sociaux
de la même manière il ya une
racialisation de la société française
c'est une réalité qui a à la fois ses
ressorts historique il ya l'esclavagisme
au colonialisme le néocolonialisme
au lieu de l'impérialisme aussi et puis
évidemment au quotidien de ceux et
celles qui vivent dont on parle pas
suffisamment dans ce qu'on appelait les
dom tom c'est à dire ces territoires
outre-mer dans dans lesquels évidemment
il ya une population a crû et évidemment
parce que ce sont de fait des anciennes
colonies
juste une chose moi je ne dis pas
comment on doit se vivre ce qu'on peut
se réaliser par assises et c'est pas mon
propos ce que je sais c'est que la
police ne se comporte pas de la même
manière
enfin deux populations qui ont un peu
plus de mélanine que d'autres que la
justice de la même manière que lorsque
l'on va dans différents institutions on
n'est pas traité à égalité alors nous ne
demandons pas l'égalité des choses parce
qu'on n'est pas en compétition
nous demandons l'égalité des droits
l'égalité des droits ce sont des beaux
combats qui ont été menées que mène
encore actuellement les femmes de la
même manière ceux et celles qui sont
victimes du racisme structurel demande
l'égalité des droits
et de ce point de vue là je finirai
juste là dessus que monsieur macron son
gouvernement et tous ces intellectuels
l'aréopage qui est derrière début ou
devant lui entendent bien que ceux et
celles qui se sont mobilisés le 10
novembre contre l'islamophobie
et bien ré occuperont sans aucun doute
la rue les tribunes feront du bruit les
réseaux sociaux pour dire que la france
telle que la ville ne se fera pas sur
notre dos c'est à dire quelques-uns
qu'on va montrer du doigt et
régulièrement
ça s'appelle une oppression ça s'appelle
une résistance à existe depuis la nuit
des temps et donc on a placé tout seul
qui veulent lutter contre tous les
racismes à se retrouver et
accessoirement à lire le livre racisme
de france ça s'arrête ici on a déjà deux
minutes de retard merci d'avoir de nous
avoir suivis merci d'avoir possible à ce
débat merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]